Hello everyone, welcome back to another episode of the Grand Prixquel Podcast, where we discuss
all things feeder series.
Today's episode is going to be a bit of a long one, because we're covering 6 different championships.
We are covering F2, F3, and F1 Academy at Silverstone, Eurocup 3 at Imola, E4 at Vallelunga,
and FREC at the Hungaroring.
Your hosts for today are myself, Robin, Nova, Peter, Evan, and Alex.
So I feel like F2 was, I mean, it was an interesting weekend overall, I feel like, in terms of
the championship standings maybe, because it was utter Tsolov domination when it got
to the races.
We finally had the Grand Prixquel curse break.
My prediction of Tsolov being- leading the championship at Silverstone finally happened.
Thank you to whoever stopped cursing the podcast, at the same time I think the podcast is still cursed.
Now we just need to wait for the end of the year to see if he actually wins, because given our luck.
Even if he doesn't, because all I wanted was Mini not to lead, and well I got that finally.
I'm not going to make any more predictions, because I think that's too much.
I mean, to be fair, there are certain drivers that we haven't cursed before, like,
there are a couple episodes where we're talking about James Egozi being really good,
and then he just continued to be really good afterwards.
Yeah, I mean, I did call him a Winter Series merchant though, so you need to remember that.
But yeah, qualifying, I think across all three series, we saw a lot of track limits violations.
Like, everybody was getting their laps deleted.
Did anyone not get their laps deleted?
Did we have more track limits here than in Austria?
Yeah, because I think in Austria it's more self-policing, because of course you have
the gravel on the exit.
Whereas in Silverstone, you go somewhere like Copse, there's quite a few people going over there.
There is no gravel, so there is no self-policing.
Yeah, I mean, it's just, I mean, we had a Camara pole, I felt like a Camara pole, he
feels inevitable almost, he's always going to be up there.
And I found Tsolov’s radio quite interesting.
So he did his lap, he went P1 up to first, but then he had the likes of Camara, Dunnee, overtake
him, but he was like, I can't do better than that, that's the best I can do.
Yeah, that was so weird.
Like, your best lap was good enough for like, where was he?
Like, P5?
How is your best lap only good enough for P5 and you cannot do anything more than that?
It's just an interesting comment to hear, like, surely I feel like if it was any other
driver that would try to push and push more of the limits, like push the limits as much
as they could, but Tsolov just outright flatly, like, just flat out saying to his engineer, oh, like
that's all I can do, it's just interesting, you don't really hear that from, like, drivers.
Yeah, I feel like he was close, he was nearly three tenths off what Camara did.
Like, it was not even close.
Invicta needs to be investigated.
Yeah, because they were in comparison to everyone else, because Camara was two tenths
ahead of Dunne, so behind Dunne he's not too far off, he's less than a tenth off.
He maybe just, maybe shows how good the pace of the Invicta is.
I don't know, but that's a really, like, we know, we know- we saw just how good Tsolov was
in the sprint and feature race.
I mean, the sprint race.
To manage to overtake into the lead in both races when you're not near the front in either of them.
Yeah.
That's, that's really impressive.
He just had good start, I mean, the Sprint race, I mean, he just had a good start,
and he just had great pace.
I mean, but I think we need to talk about whatever that Bennett and Montoya crash was.
It felt very British F4-esque.
Maybe it's just me.
I think, I think Montoya went, I think Montoya went off somewhere,
Bennett tried to avoid him, and they just kind of collided together.
Like, I watched the crash, and I was like, damn, this looks like something that would
happen in British F4.
I mean, even after watching it, I still can't, can't figure out what exactly happened.
Really looked like Bennett got mega-chromed on, like, the straight.
Yeah, I thought he got mega-chromed at first, but then you saw, then we hear,
oh no, Montoya's pulled off to the side as well.
And it's like, oh, who are the smoke coming out?
It's always these sort of guys involved in these incidents.
Yeah, exactly.
It's like, not really surprising.
Yeah, and Camara had a really bad start.
He lost four places.
I don't think it was starting, I think I was just in general.
When I wrote those notes down, I think I was just in general, but the point was that
Camara did not do good at that race.
Yeah, he lost like, he lost like two places off the line, then he got overtaken, kind
of got swamped.
He tried to make it back up, but.
I think he did eventually, from what I remember.
I think he finished P10, so he started where he started, he finished where he started,
I guess, but it's like, he was just pretty bad, like, throughout the race.
He, he did eventually get up there, get up to P10 again, but.
And yeah, it's just kind of, given the pace we know the Invicta has, I mean, he's
taken three pole positions, that Invicta is fast.
He's just not able to execute the races half the time.
Has something happened to Stenshorne?
I mean, what is going on with him now?
Like, he has been, not great for a good couple weekends now.
He's on like a three-race, like a three-race weekend, non-scoring streak.
He's inherited it from Dunne, just constantly causing incidents, and just, he's taken,
he's taken it from Dunne.
Dunne is now a clean racer, and Stenshorne is doing whatever the hell he's doing.
Yeah, I mean, Stenshorne, I feel like he can be solid at times, it's not like he's a
generational-he's not like a Tsolov or someone who really stands out.
But yeah, I mean, I do expect more of him, he's still solid, I think he should be in
the points every week.
I just don't know what's happened to him since Monaco.
Hopefully in Spa we’ll see him return to his normal form, I mean.
Or maybe Rodin don’t want both their drivers near each other.
Also, that last lap move from Tsolov at the end, for the lead of the race, or the win
essentially, amazing, perfect, I think that was the best out of the entire
F2 weekend, because that entire F2 weekend, as you'll find out, is that- I did not enjoy
it as much.
I think I recognize F3 was a lot better, which I mean, it was, objectively.
There's like no nothing in F2.
The racing was just boring, but then Tsolov, and I think Tsolov has really evolved over
the last few years, where he's now able to time the move, and he's getting better and
better at doing that, and learning when to go for a move, when not to go for a move.
I think I remember, what was it?
Was it Australia 2024? Where Tsolov made that really dirty move on, like
he's come a long way from that.
Yeah, he crashed into Dunne on purpose.
In qualifying, yeah no.
He's come over, oh, it's like they're interlinked, wait.
I mean, I think this weekend we just saw the best of Tsolov.
I saw a tweet once that said that Tsolov crashing into Dunne on purpose in Australia 2024
was what changed Dunne’s brain chemistry, and made him super crash prone.
Honestly, I believe that.
But Dunne has finally evolved.
I think after Canada, he realized.
I think he had like a moment, I think it's finally awoken in him, because
at the start of the season, we were like, not again this guy, but.
I just think it's a bit sad that Rodin is just not that good.
Yeah, but at least he's still getting started finishing, that's the best he can do.
And moving on to the future race.
I mean, Tsolov had a great start.
He started P5, got up to P2.
Maini went to the lead.
The front row was just slow in getting off.
That Camara start was bad.
Yeah, I mean, he fell to P3.
Dunne fell to P4.
I mean, whatever happened to the front two, it was just slow off the line.
I find it really funny that the commentators for F2 both of them,
said that Tsolov had a bad start.
And initially I read that in, because I did not see the start.
Because I think my stream was breaking or whatever.
But it's really funny how they said bad start when, well, Tsolov did not have a bad start.
He had the opposite of that.
He had a pretty good start.
It was either that, or he was just really, yeah.
Or he was just also really aided by the fact that the front row was really bad.
But even then, still, I think he, like, if you watch back the replay,
I think he had a great start.
Pretty decent start.
Yeah, honestly, I feel like it's not too much to say about the future race.
Because nothing really happened.
Tsolov overtook for the lead, as he always does.
And I mean, what else?
Maini is somehow on the podium, because.
Oh my god, Maini podium.
Yeah, that was, I don't know, again, money talks real hard at ART, it seems.
There was the whole, like, strategy thing as well.
Like, the guys that went on the softs at the end were really good.
Yeah, I mean, that's kind of, like, if you even saw in Spain,
you get a tyre delta and kind of go away with it.
But Tsolov had built such a big lead in the front
that he just didn't fall victim to Villagomez at the end.
Imagine if we got a Villagomez win.
That would have really just shown how bad, like, F2 is.
He went from last in the standings to, like, what, P10 or something now?
Yeah, because he was on podium last weekend too.
Oh my god.
Yeah, it's tense now.
Like, he's only, I love how Villagomez only scored points three times
and on three of those times are podiums.
VAR, their entire philosophy is,
either you get a podium or you don't get anything.
Two of those podiums are sprint podiums as well.
Villagomez is not real.
F2 is not real.
This means Tsolov has now won three races in a row
and this is his sixth win of the season.
To put that into perspective,
no one else this season has won more than one race and he's won six.
That's crazy.
It’s a real stat.
I mean, it sounds fake, but it's real.
I promise I'm not lying to you guys.
We've never spread misinformation on the Grand Prix pod.
That is not a thing we do ever.
We've never done that before.
And as we alluded to earlier,
this means Tsolov has finally broken the curse.
And he has a decent margin now.
He's leading by 17 points.
I think the difference between Tsolov and Mini is,
Mini's been ultra consistent.
There's only been one race where Mini hasn't scored any points
whereas Tsolov can hack at really high highs.
But he's also had a few DNFs, a few non-point scorers,
which have not been his fault.
To be fair to him, he's been a bit unlucky compared to Mini maybe.
But I hope he can actually show his quality
because he is the best driver in this field.
To me at least, it's not really a question of it.
It is quite a weak field,
especially I think because we've had so many guys go up to F1.
And then the other good guys in F3,
F2 just kind of left in the middle without having anyone.
I mean, the fact that Leon is P5,
I think explains a lot about that.
Like we've just, the quality that we have this year
is just not up to what we've expected.
Especially last year was a really decent grid in my opinion.
Or 2024 was insane.
Nothing can beat 2024 F2.
I can't believe we might have the best driver in the field
actually win the championship.
I mean, it helps when everyone else is kind of.
When was the last time the best driver in the field won the championship?
That's a stat for someone to research.
In my personal unbiased opinion, 2023.
Yeah, that's true.
But no, I don't think I won that year.
I'd say Victor Martins, though, was quite good.
Fred Vesti, they were both quite good that year as well.
Yeah, honestly, 2023 was a great year.
But I think I only say 2023
because Tare was really consistent with getting on the podium,
getting like first points.
Because I do remember back on F1 for us, back in the day,
people were just absolutely angry.
Back in my day, three years ago.
Youngest one here.
I was going to mention that.
Yeah, he's young.
People used to be so upset over Vesti not winning the championship.
And of course, it was the last race shootout, essentially, for it.
But I was like, oh, he won more races.
Therefore, he deserves to win on merit.
I was like, well, that's not how it works.
Poor Tare was just more consistent.
He was getting more podiums.
He was getting into the points more often.
Vesti, to be fair, that year, though, had a bit of bad luck.
Zandvoort, when they didn't attach his tires properly
and he just spun around at the end.
That was really funny.
That was really funny for me as a Vesti, as a Porsche FN.
But very bad luck for him.
But honestly, I don't think we've had a proper good winner
who was the fastest Vest driver win since 2023, at least.
Yeah, because 2024, the teams, Prema and ART,
I don't know what they did with his new car.
How do you fumble a Berman Antonelli lineup?
I was just surprised because ART was the fastest car.
To be fair, we had new regulations.
So it's not like we're new cars.
I was going to say ART was the fastest in 2023,
but we all know that there are.
Honestly, I was a bit of a...
Not many payers were doing it, in my opinion,
because every other year had been Prema, essentially.
Winning the championship.
So almost.
Not consistently, but mainly Prema.
And I guess now, instead of Prema and ART,
we have Invicta and Campos.
Except it's basically Invicta and Campos now.
And Kamar, I mean, Tsolove,
is just able to get everything out of the Campos he is.
Ability-wise, Kamar, I think maybe Kamar,
he has one lap pace, but he's not able to fully...
He has three poles, but he's only one, one way.
I think, yeah, I was going to say that.
It probably explains a lot as to why
he just can't do well in the races.
And he has his third...
He's third in the championship,
but he's 30 points behind Mini.
And that means he's nearly 50 points.
46 to be exact, if I'm...
Maths is 47 behind Tsolove.
That's nearly two race wins,
two future race wins off the lead.
And people say that this guy is ready for F1 as well.
I'm just saying.
I know, actually, he's not representative.
We talk about this all the time on the podcast,
how F2 is the most inconsistent,
like the most...
Nothing in F2 actually makes sense at all,
because everything is wrong.
Everything does not work.
But considering the fact that the Invicta is the fastest car,
like is essentially the fastest car,
usually, lap on lap, like...
On one lap pace, Steph.
And also on the tires.
We saw in Spain how much longer he was able
to keep the tires alive compared to everyone else.
And I also just make the subject of it.
Invicta has been the fastest car in the world
since the start of regulations.
But I think the other people finally caught up,
and tuned their car bit by bit.
Mechachrome is not affecting them as badly as it was
at the start of 2024,
where we just see every team but Invicta
have engine problems, honestly.
So I think now that we're in our third year of the new car,
or third season, I should say, technically,
I think Invicta is just no longer that fast car
team as it used to be.
It looks like how Premo used to be the fastest in F2.
I mean, you can see it in the team's championship as well,
Invicta's fourth.
But then again, Dirkson, I mean,
I think it's just due to lineups.
It's just due to lineup, because...
Like, MP, honestly, is a bit impressive.
I would say it's impressive that they're P2,
but that's also because they've been carried by Mini
at the same time, so like...
Yeah, I mean, it's the same with Campos.
I mean, Tsolov on his own would be
third in the championship,
team's championship, the amount of points he has.
And he's only...
He'd be second by one point,
because Rodin's on 140, he's on 141 by himself.
Yeah, he'd be third, because MP...
Oh no, yeah.
Like, if you ignore Campos.
He'd be second, and it's not...
He only has 11 points left, which is...
And yeah, it just shows how good he's been,
and...
That's kind of insane, actually.
Yeah, I think that's enough Tsolov glazing from us,
and now it's time for me to glaze Rodin's later.
I need to do this, I'm sorry.
It was not pre-climb anyway, it was gonna happen.
I mean, he's been mega fast the whole weekend.
Okay, he could disqualify from practice
if he did something with a few,
but he was faster than qualifying.
Oh, his session was really interesting.
Yeah, so like in qualifying,
so his first lap got due to the track limit,
but in his second lap went P1.
Third lap went even faster, P1.
Something about him and Silverstone,
I mean, he's always been faster than Silverstone.
In GB3 last year, he took two wins.
In Trinity Junior, he's won like six races here.
He's really good at Silverstone,
I mean, he's the home crowd.
It was looking to be a great weekend.
Let's cover the sprint before we get to the feature, though.
Yeah, no, I think it's more about qualifying.
I mean, Niall and the Nugatja crew,
they had to the last,
they got their first two laps deleted,
that dude at the end.
Ugo eventually got his lap weird stated,
but there's still the pressure on them.
And DiPaolo McLaughlin finally having a good weekend.
I think it helped McLaughlin
because he's finally at a circuit he's raced at before.
None of the circuits have raced at before.
I think it maybe helped him getting some confidence
because we saw him qualify sixth in the end,
which, yeah, it's really good for him.
As you said, onto the sprint.
Ugo, I mean, Ugo is dominant in that.
Yeah, Ugo really was.
Just that, what was it, like a 10th?
Over 15 seconds.
Yeah, over 15 seconds of a margin.
But we do need to preface that word.
Johan David, what a defense for P2.
Yes, oh my days.
And an AIX as well.
That was impressive.
He had like a train from P2 to P9 or something at the end.
And he was just holding them off so well.
It was really impressive to see.
Because, I don't know, he was playing dirty as well.
He was doing it cleanly.
He was changing lines a lot and making brake checkings.
He was doing it cleanly as well,
which makes it even more impressive.
And yeah, to talk about Freddie,
he had a bit of a poor start.
I mean, I don't know what he was doing at the start.
He was bumming around at the start or whatever.
But he eventually made up places in the last four or five laps.
He made up like five places.
He was taking time as he overtakes well.
Yeah, I mean, I enjoyed Freddie's race a lot.
And the other two tridents are...
I don't know why these tridents can't race each other cleanly.
Because again, it's to understand in the parlour
they made light contact with each other.
And they, I mean, if they'd worked together with Niall,
they probably could have gotten to David.
But they didn't work well together.
And then he ended up kind of going into each other
and hindering each other.
And yeah, I mean, I have opinions in the parlour,
which we'll get to later.
And I think it's also good to mention that not just...
I think that's also what helped with Niall
like making up that amount of positions.
He made up about...
He went 11th to 3rd.
Yeah.
He had a really good start.
He went from like 3rd to 8th or 7th at the start.
And then he was just kind of holding his pace.
I mean, Niall has been one of the...
He's been one of the best drivers we've seen.
He's been a bit unlucky at times.
At least in this print.
He was able to show what he's able to do.
And the parlour and McLaughlin finally got that first point.
And we had the feature race.
Oh.
I'll let you take it away, I think.
No, my bet's at the end.
Okay.
But you know, first, I'll start with the good stuff.
Freddie had a good getaway in Poland, but Niall...
They were quite equal off the line, it felt like.
And Niall was challenging, but Freddie managed to keep the lead.
But then, yeah, de Paolo eventually got up to 2nd.
And at the start, it seemed like Niall and Freddie were just letting de Paolo pass
because he was going to tuck his tyres, which he did at first.
Freddie eventually got back ahead.
And then de Paolo managed to overtake him.
And then the safety car came out.
After a few laps of de Paolo being in the lead.
And yeah, it's led to a one lap shootout and...
I was in an interesting one lap shootout, to say the least, between the first two.
De Paolo is just...
Okay, I don't know what he was doing, because, okay, finally he can raise a teammate.
But please do it cleanly.
He's busy.
He's moving around, he's not taking the proper line.
He's not accelerating like he normally would.
He's braking way earlier than he should.
Yeah, I was going to play devil's advocate, just then.
And say, well, Freddie went into the back of him twice at the same time.
De Paolo was not racing...
Cleanly.
That's because he was accelerating like normal.
Where is Freddie meant to go if the guy in front of him is not moving like he normally would?
And like, and in the end...
Yeah, that final little wheel tap.
I mean, de Paolo, fine racing, but just do it cleanly.
And you ended up crashing the team, the 1-2.
I mean, okay, I am biased that he's over Freddie.
And all of that probably gets disqualified.
It gets calmer.
He got disqualified.
I think the theory...
I saw a theory, or like, a joke theory,
of maybe the problem with his diffuser was because Freddie kept going into the back of him.
I mean, deserve.
If you're not going to accelerate like normal and brake way too early,
then you deserve that.
I'm sorry.
I think he had a plan there.
Freddie had a plan.
As soon as he knew that De Paolo was not going to let it go,
I think he had a plan.
And that was his plan.
Yeah, but I mean, try not to sort it out, whatever it is.
There's two times where he's been screwed over by his teammates in the last two race weekends.
It's just crazy that De Paolo had the audacity like just then.
He just got his first point, literally the day before.
But he can race cleanly.
I'm following him racing.
Just please do it cleanly.
I mean, it's strong stead.
I mean, to be fair to what Evan said about De Paolo scoring his first points the day before,
maybe it was desperation to score more points that had him do what he did.
It was desperation.
And I think he probably has the pressure from McLaren.
Yeah, exactly.
I was going to say that.
He's not been performing to the level that he should be in the Trident, for example.
And so if he wants to keep his academy backing, he's desperate, basically.
Oh, so how does this look to an academy if you're desperately?
It goes both ways.
But I am just annoyed, if you can't tell.
I don't crash that often on the podcast, but...
Yeah, huh?
Funny this was finished P2 in the end,
really literally everybody getting penalties.
Can I list out the penalties?
Can I do that?
Yes.
Okay, so De Paolo got disqualified for his diffuser height.
Rivera, Giusti, and Wharton all got penalties for weaving,
now got a penalty during the race for, I think, leaving the track and gaining an advantage.
And Ho Chi and McDonklin and Baron Bakhti all got penalties for track limits.
This means we end up with a Gladys Flayton-Ugrutraku podium.
I'm really happy for Gladys.
He had a great weekend.
I saw the F3 post that said he was the 67th.
Freaking Twitter.
Oh my god, 67th.
And it was on the 67th.
It should have been Enzo.
Mr. 67th himself.
Enzo was like P15 or something.
VAR were not having a great weekend, unfortunately.
I feel like Del Pino still did.
He had a good quali- No, he did not.
I am lying.
None of them had good qualifying.
He had a good win, but actually never mind, guys.
I thought he did, but no, he didn't.
The only points that VAR scored this weekend were Yamakoshi in
the feature race after Half The Grader got penalized.
This was so funny, and yeah.
I wonder if Trident should have told Freddie and De Palo that Gnar is probably penalized,
because maybe the race would have turned out differently if they didn't know Gnar was a threat
because he's going to get a penalty.
Yeah, possibly.
We need to be careful because I don't know why that took so long to announce the penalty.
FD Steward, that should have been announced earlier.
That happened on lap 4 or something.
The incident where he forced somebody wide.
Who was it?
He gained an advancement way off track, but if that had been announced earlier,
I wonder how the entry would have turned out.
I don't think De Palo would have been as desperate to keep the position
if he knew that Gnar was being penalized.
Even Freddie, he's like, fine, let Gnar go ahead, he's going to get a penalty anyways.
Knows what would have happened.
Yes, going into the tramp, because despite Ugo qualifying P12,
he actually extended his tramping to lead, I think.
I think the top two are breaking away quite a bit from the rest of the field.
There's a 27-point gap between Slater and Nile.
To be fair, Nile has been fast, he's been a bit unlucky.
He's been fast, he's not fully able to execute things.
He has three pole positions.
He's on the front row this weekend, he's only had one bad qualifying,
which was last time the weekend before at Austria.
He's just not able to fully put the weekend together for whatever reason.
And yeah, even Ugo, he has a decent lead now.
I mean, he has what?
He has a 17-point lead, which is pretty sizable.
But in F3, we thought it was Nile, one bad qualifying in F3,
they're qualifying down in P28.
That's a weekend gone.
And Freddie, please lock him in Spa, I can't.
Enzo is out of the top 10, which I'm kind of sad about.
He's not had a good last few weekends.
I think Villar is locked.
Everything in Spain has been struggling as a team.
Yeah, they used up all of their pace from the season in Spain, and now it's all gone.
I mean, I want to say, Slater and Neste Rivero for now being P11 in the points,
despite missing the first race weekend.
That's quite impressive to come back from a back injury beyond the pace
and be P11 is quite impressive, I think.
I really feel like he could have been really high up in the championship
if he hadn't missed Australia.
Maybe P11, maybe top five or something.
I mean, I can't see in the comp, I can't try to call the best two cars.
I think we tried again, I started really showing this pace in the last two weekends.
We've now seen Stromstedt and Depello out of nowhere as finally up there as well.
Before the first few weekends, it was only really Freddie up there.
But now Stromstedt is joining the party.
P4 in the championship, albeit 30 points behind Freddie.
Niamh.
Depello raced on Silverstone before?
No, then thank you.
Niamh.
Because I was going to say, for him and Finn McLaughlin,
it could be a thing of experience because obviously Finn has raced on Silverstone before,
so just being on a track that you raced before really, really helps.
But if Depello hasn't raced in Silverstone before,
then I'm not sure where this sudden amount of pace has come from.
He raced in Barcelona before.
He did two years of freqa.
Niamh.
Not sure then.
And he also did Spanish R4,
so that means he has like three race weekends in Barcelona.
Niamh.
You'd think he would have won Barcelona then.
But yeah, at least the experiencing explains Finn's performance this weekend.
Niamh.
I think it's quite obvious he's going to do a second season,
and the fact that he's able to bring pace to a circuit he knew,
I think that's just a promise for next year,
because we saw last year in British R4 how good he was.
It's been a tough, it's a massive step up.
Most drivers, he's a bit solid-like in a way.
We saw Tsolov skip.
You know, it's good to compare him to Tsolov.
Yeah, it means Red Bull at the time,
no, he was an alpine junior at the time,
but a good driver going straight,
and not from like the main Italian F4.
I think Italian F4, and it's in the last few years,
he's been kind of the top series.
British F4, Spanish F4, maybe a step below.
From that to go straight up to F2,
you are going to struggle.
I mean, very few drivers have successful jumps.
I mean, in recent years,
I can think of Berman went to F4 to F3,
and Antonelli went Formula Regional to F2.
I can't really think of, and Lindblad as well, skipped Formula Regional,
but these are like, these guys are all in F1 now,
and are performing extremely well in F1.
Then McLaughlin to be the next F1 driver.
You heard it here first.
And they're on the championship teams.
Yeah, Campos have a 42-point lead,
and I don't see that point lead coming down any time soon.
Yeah, all three of their drivers have been performing quite well,
and I mean, the car was great, so.
It's a combination of everything,
good drivers, good car, good team,
the team operationally.
Yeah, I think F3 has shown the best racing this weekend.
Overall, they were really fun races to watch.
I think Silverstone is a great circuit.
I am biased, because I dislike Silverstone,
but I feel like maybe in F2, F1 Academy,
for some reason everyone's racing as well,
but F3 was just amazing racing.
Going from what was really good racing
to what was possibly the most boring race weekend,
like racing series this weekend.
Frek, I have no words to explain how boring those races were.
I say we just eliminated the whole weekend
and pretend it never happened in terms of the points.
We're not eliminating the whole weekend.
Please.
We have three hosts on right now
who have very different opinions about this weekend.
We can all agree, yes, it was boring,
but what it implied for all of our reps,
you will see in a moment.
You have three very, very different opinions,
because I thought it was great.
Yeah, of course, always.
We always had what?
Two 1-2s, two DNFs.
Before we get into the racing,
we had another new driver for CL Motorsport.
Noah Lyle, who was meant to do GB3, right?
Yeah.
Just left before the season started due to some personal issues.
I don't remember what exactly it was.
I feel like it's all probably funding related.
He may be lost out on funding for GB3,
but now he's got some funding back to maybe do some work.
Yeah, he said family and money problems,
I remember in his post when he first dropped out of GB3.
Yeah, he was in for it this weekend,
because all of CL's drivers that they had before
were busy racing in their own series.
To start off with Quali...
Oh, my God.
...Welfire was great.
We had an R-Race 1-3-4 with Sano Ampol,
Elvary 3rd, and Olivier 4th,
and the only person supporting them was Swirthen.
Out of nowhere, because he's not been very good so far.
Yeah.
He hasn't been a standout driver so far this season.
But then again, we had the G4.
Where did this G4 pace come from?
The G4 pace and then the arts also were doing randomly really well,
but oh my gosh, there was a moment in qualifying
where Alma Sergi got overall pole for a good,
I think, like a good few laps,
and I was sitting there and I was gripping my seat
and I'm like, we're going to have a G4 pole.
We're going to have a G4 pole.
Luckily, RSGP saved us from a G4 pole.
Thank you, Yuki Sano.
I did not like the qualifying step.
He was only P9.
Ian was P12, pole man himself.
He had a better race though.
Oh, well true.
Yeah.
I'll give you that.
I was really surprised to see Sano on pole.
Like I saw RS's pace over the weekend
and I was thinking like maybe Alvaria or Olivier pole
and then the other two would be like right behind.
I was not expecting Sano on pole.
Sano and Alvaria were one and two in their quali group
and then I was really hoping Olivier
would end up first in his quali group
but he ended up second behind Soerthen.
Stoltzermanis had a pretty decent qualifying.
Was he the best Prema?
Yes.
Yeah, I was going to mention that he was the best Prema
and yeah, it went Stoltzermanis,
Kian and then Hanna, I think.
What were the top 10?
There's something in Nihangaro Ring Air.
And then the CLs were also randomly really good.
Like Franco was in P5 for quali
and there were moments where the others were also setting
like pretty good paces and I was like, what is going on?
But yeah, so great quality from RSVP.
I love this French team.
Yeah, literally nothing happened.
Like Alvaria overtook Soerthen on the start
and Weldon spun at one point
and that's literally everything that happened.
Yeah, I mean, it's so bad.
He couldn't overtake at Al-Masjidri.
He just couldn't overtake over there.
It was so bad.
He tried to overtake him and went into the grass and spun.
Yeah.
Don't remind me, please.
What is this top 10 again?
I mean, it's just he couldn't do it.
It's not like once you were, everybody was going,
can I change positions?
Here it's like, nobody can change positions.
You're going to stay where you were at the end of lap one.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Kian was chasing Kabir Anarag of all people for like every single lap
and he never could make a move.
Kian was chasing Anarag, Sepp was chasing Al-Masjidri.
This reminds me of the four regional Middle East race that I watched live.
Where Alex Powell was stuck behind Anarag the entire race.
And it's not like the race two in quality was any better?
Well, it was still a race one, two, what was it?
Was it one, two, four?
Or was it one, three, four?
I don't remember.
For race one?
For race two.
Oh, race two was after Penn or before Penn?
I meant for qualifying.
Oh, qualifying, I don't remember.
I don't remember either, but it was either one, two, four or one, three, four.
So again, really, really good quality performance.
I mean, that race was a little bit more interesting.
We had a couple incidents.
Unfortunately, Yuki stalled on the start.
Oh, a piece on us.
I was really sad about it.
I really thought it was Olivier for a second.
And I had Austria flashbacks.
Because he literally stalled all three starts there.
But it was not Olivier.
It was Sano, unfortunately.
I feel really bad that he got his first race win the day before
and then he stalls on the start in the second race.
But yeah, so Weldon had an engine failure of sorts?
Yes.
On July 4th weekend, the American was doing bad.
No point the whole weekend.
Peter, now you know how it feels, how I felt during Portimao.
At one point, Nova, your driver will also suffer a double DNF.
I mean, Austria, I think, was bad enough.
Austria was horrendous.
He did well in the first two races, though.
But he needed a double DNF.
And he did get a double pole that weekend.
So he needed the experience of whatever the series goes.
Speaking of primary DNFs.
I don't know what happened between him and Sols Ramonis.
They did not show a replay.
Because once again, TV direction is not great.
But no replay, they just collided and Gauda got a 10 second penalty for it.
So, and then Hannah got crashed into by Newman Chi.
Most normal Newman Chi activities.
Something I realized was that the two current Prima drivers
were both crashed into by former Prima drivers.
Oh my god.
Everything that happened during this race
happened to someone who used to be connected with Prima.
And also, for some reason, the commentator during this round
kept on bringing up that Rashid used to be part of Prima.
Like, he kept on saying the ex-Prima man, now the current RACE man.
And I don't know why he fell the knee.
And he kept saying that Rashid was the sprint king.
I feel like an insult.
What do I mean by sprint king?
I feel like an insult if you're calling me a sprint merchant.
And also, he just didn't notice that Sano stalled.
He was just like, oh my god, what happened to Yuki Sano?
He's like P20 something on our timings.
Is that a Twin Splendor issue?
That was like lap 10.
Yeah.
But yeah, so Chi also got a 10 second penalty for the collision with Hana.
Yes.
The race ended under a safety car, which meant that anyone who got post-race penalties
got really screwed over.
And that happens to Abkazawa, who initially finished the racing P2,
but got a penalty for a race mode infringement.
So his 6 second penalty, I still find these weirdly specific numbers really funny.
But the 6 second penalty dropped him down to P20 something, I think.
I thought it was P14.
Was it P20 something?
I don't remember.
But it would have dropped him down really low because of the safety car.
So it promoted Olivieri up to P2 and promoted KMB to the podium.
So he gets to keep his podium streak.
Yay! Also, Abkazawa was only put down to P13.
That's why I got confused.
Yeah, only P13.
That's why I said P20 something.
I was like, that feels way too low.
I really thought it was P20 something.
Ian gets to keep his podium streak.
Yay.
And then this means we have Aldehaver leading the championship and that was P3.
21 points ahead of KMB.
Who's 9 points ahead of Serb.
And then Olivieri has really closed the gap down.
I mean, it's the top four we thought it was going to be going into the season.
Exactly.
Olivieri has closed down the gap to 5 points behind Weldon.
And then you have Franco down in P5 with 84 points, which is?
I read the Freedom Series article about this race weekend and they usually put the rookie
standings as well as the overall standings on the team standings.
And what I found really funny was the rookie standings are just however many normal points
the rookies have scored.
So it's just like the standings of the rookies, I don't know how to explain it,
but I hope you get what I mean.
And so because Olivieri is on 116 points in the normal standings,
he's leading the rookie standings.
Obviously, he's the highest rookie.
The second highest rookie is Alex Munoz, who is on 37 points.
37?
That's really funny.
Hydrogen bomb versus coughing baby.
I kept saying that this entire weekend.
116 points versus 37 points.
Um, team's championship is great, by the way.
I love it here.
Um, our race is leading on 322 points ahead of MP on 212.
We are 110 points ahead of MP.
And Prema is only two points behind MP.
Rodin is a good hundred points behind Prema.
And then CLP is a couple of points behind Rodin as well.
So at least one of our predictions is happening,
which is the RACE team championship.
It is nice to see that.
I think maybe RACE are just further ahead
because they have two drivers who are consistently in Aldoher and Olivieri.
And Sano's a really consistent point scorer as well now.
Exactly.
Whereas MP only really have Sepp, Prema only really have Kian.
I mean, to be fair, Chi and Abkhazava are both consistent point scorers,
but that's about it.
They don't compete for race wins or anything.
Yeah, in that sense.
Whereas, because you see the top five, in top four, two of them are always.
And it's really nice to have multiple people in contention every weekend.
It makes it a fun championship.
Can we just erase the points from this weekend, please?
No.
No thanks.
I would quite like to keep the current points.
Well, mine doesn't matter.
He's still in P2 anyways.
He's maintaining his P2.
Sepp, please lock him in their castle 8.
Please, I can't do this.
So moving on to Eurocup 3.
For once, I don't have much to complain about.
Oh, well, I do have a little bit to complain about
because Campos was kind of nowhere during quali, at least.
In a way, they've been like this the whole season.
They've not been on it, like they haven't literally over the championship.
Exactly.
We discussed this in the last episode,
but they kind of just sacrificed their Eurocup 3 pace for every other championship
because aren't they leading every other championship that they're in?
But I think I prefer my other theory that Alex Palau is a witch.
So during qualifying, it was a sprint weekend this time.
So both quali sessions were on the same day, like right after each other.
So Lammerz caused a red flag during quali 1, I believe.
And so I'm pretty sure his car was too damaged to even do anything in quali 2.
So he's kind of starting in the back for all three races.
So that really changed up where he was in the championship, obviously.
Palau Motorsport domination.
1, 2, 4, and then 24 for both quali sessions.
Obviously it was a go-ze on pole.
P24 with Bianca Bustamante, are we really surprised?
Not really.
I don't remember which quali had Perrard in P2 and which one had Delaniel in P2,
but one of them had Perrard P2, Delaniel P4, and the other one had Delaniel P2 and Perrard P4.
I think Delaniel, he's probably P2 in the quali 1,
because I think he started on the front where we remember,
start of race 1, and of course we know what happened, we'll get on to the race.
Probably, but I don't remember.
Campos, during both quali sessions, all their drivers qualified between 10th and 20th.
I think the highest quali position was Torbenescu in P10.
And then during quali 2, I think it was Hoizenroeder that was P20,
but Hoizenroeder in quali 1 ended up P12, so ended up on the reverse pole for the sprint race.
Powell's quali was not great.
He was P13 for race 1 and the sprint race, and then P16 for race 2.
But yeah, we can kind of just see how good Campos has been.
We've seen that they weren't very good before,
but even then Powell was qualifying in the top 5.
Now Powell's not even close to the top 5.
Maybe Alex Powell cast them.
It's either Alex or one of the Alexes' faults.
Polo or Powell, take your pick.
Alex Powell is also cast.
So moving on to base 1, Igosi was leading the race for a good part of it,
and then suddenly his car- what's the Eurocup 3 equivalent of Mechachrome?
He just died.
His car just stopped.
You know the Mechachrome alchemy that they've done for the day?
That was his car.
Oh yeah, I was complaining about TV direction a lot during that race,
and I had the live timing open and I saw that Delaniel had gotten past Igosi and I was like,
why did they not show us the overtake for the lead?
And then suddenly everyone else starts overtaking Igosi and I'm like, wait what?
And then eventually they do show it on the broadcast that he's just stopped.
And then he got going again, then parked it at the pit entry.
Which was a smart thing to do, I guess.
He stopped, gave us the chance to actually get some racing at the end in case his car died again,
because you never know with these things.
They come back to life and they die again.
It was a really good race 1.
Yeah, race 1 was great, and I swear it's not because of the results.
Powell went from P13 up to P3, and after something that we're going to discuss in a second,
he ended up P2.
Hater Delaniel won the race, but he got a 5 second penalty for forcing Kiano Alazari off the track.
However, they are still appealing that penalty.
So race 1 results are still not official until now.
I hope they don't rescind the penalty, just because I really want that P2.
Clean up everyone but Alex and give Alex the win.
Exactly.
And you'd think that with Igosi DNFing, it would have really big championship implications,
but it did not.
He has such a big lead that the DNF just did not matter for him.
Up until this point, he's been on the podium at every single race.
Quickly, hasn't he been on the podium?
Wait, did he get a podium in race 2?
I mean, not race 2, the sprint?
No, he was like P6 or something.
But he's got points then in every race he's finished, you can say that.
And he would have won race 1 if the car didn't just die.
It's better for everyone other than him that his car died.
Back to Daniel's penalty.
Because he forced Alasari off track and there was some sort of chaos with him and Alasari
and Pradell and all that, Alasari ended up DNFing.
He DNFed again in the sprint race and that has caused a little bit of a mix-up in the
championship.
Because going into this weekend, I thought Alasari was secure P2.
I thought that was how it was going to end.
But he's P3 in the championship now, I think.
And he's right in the middle of the fight.
Yeah, he's P3.
We'll get onto the full championship standings later.
In the beginning of the race, there was a collision between Ferrari and Perouard and
I thought it was a little bit funny because it was kind of karma for both of them crashing
into Alex in Portimão.
Yeah, I feel like in race 1, Alex was able to benefit a lot from the chaos up front.
He both benefited from the chaos and also made a couple overtakes himself, which for
once we're not involved in the chaos.
I was hoping he'd do more in the final restart.
I was hoping he'd maybe get P2, maybe try a challenge for the win, but no.
He gets overtaken for P4 at first.
He gets forced to P4 somehow, which again, broadcast never showed us.
Thank you, PV Direction, I love you.
The stream froze when Heusenroeder overtook him and then he overtook Heusenroeder back
and then Heusenroeder was fighting with Stuka for P4, so then Alex was able to pull away
a little bit.
I can hope there's no emotion in the commentary.
Oh my god, I have so many complaints about the commentary.
Bring back Jake Sampson, my goat.
I miss Jake Sampson so bad.
But these commentators, even Igozi mentioned it after his Race 2 win.
He was like, you know the commentary, they had no emotion when me and Keanu both DNF'd
in Race 1, even though it was big for the championship.
I think it helps that Jake, he did karting commentary, so he knows a lot of the drivers
more personally, he's seen them grow up.
But also, if a championship leader is DNFing the race leader, that's a massive thing.
Exactly.
I'm just like, oh, he stopped.
Oh no, anyways.
Also, the bit where they were wondering whether Rene Lammers was any relation to Jan Lammers.
I think there was commentary, though, unlike E4 where he did complain a lot on this podcast.
Yeah.
We had a couple drivers in from Spanish F4 who came in for this weekend,
and notably Nacho Tunion came in and he was performing pretty well.
But he finished Race 1 in P7, but he got a 10 second penalty for using push to pass under
safety car.
What?
How do you use push to pass under safety car?
Probably, maybe he's thinking, there's probably a button he's doing, maybe he thought
of pressing the radio button and he presses the wrong button.
That's my theory.
But yeah, so 10 second penalty for Tunion obviously dropped him out of the points.
But Harrison was involved in like 10 different collisions the entire race.
And I don't remember anything anymore because he was literally just pushing everyone off
track.
He himself was going off track.
So that's basically it for the race.
However, we have a giant list of penalties.
Um, so initially, there was a really big group of drivers that were summoned all at the same
time.
The list of drivers was Borna, Stuka, Hoizenroeder, Ferrari, Cota, Pradel, Alasaray, Delaniel,
Perard, Powell, Harrison, and Trappa.
Okay.
And every single one of those drivers was summoned again later, or like their actual
incidents, except Powell.
I don't know.
I don't know what they were investigating Powell for.
I don't know why they didn't summon him again.
I don't know anything.
But obviously nothing happened to Powell.
He finally had some good luck.
Finally.
He didn't get a podium taken away by a penalty.
So Borna and Cota got summoned, and Borna got five seconds for forcing Cota off track.
Delaniel got summoned twice.
He got a reprimand for waving his flag around after he won the race.
And he got a penalty for forcing Alasaray off track, like we mentioned earlier.
Pradel and Alasaray also got summoned, and Pradel also got a penalty for forcing Alasaray
off track.
He really was a victim this whole race.
Harrison and Trappa got summoned together, and Harrison got 10 seconds for causing a
collision.
Hoizenroger, Stuka, and Perard were all summoned again, but there was no like doc for it.
So I assume it was whatever they were being investigated for was no further action.
And then Stephen Hadens got summoned separately, like outside of that huge list of drivers.
He got a 5 place grid drop for the next non-sprint race, for driving through the pit lane twice
during the reconnaissance lap.
I'm confused.
I don't know what he was doing.
Stephen Hadens kind of had a weekend of all time.
You'll see when it comes to later races.
I mean, the sprint race was certainly an event.
So the sprint race.
The start feels very remnant to the big Imola crash in Italian of 4 last year, where someone
stalled on the start, this time it was Tarn Benetjical, and just got hit from the back
by I think it was Feldman?
I don't remember who hit who, but I know Tarn Benetjical, Feldman, Panetta were involved,
and I think Fiorentino was also involved, but everyone was okay.
They bring the Imola in and this happens.
I mean, next year, who would seriously crash their next year, do we think?
I don't know.
E4.
They even race Imola in E4.
But yeah, all the drivers were okay, thankfully.
The crash looked a lot scarier than it actually was.
And during the red flag period, they were showing us remnants of the cars.
But after the whole red flag period, they went back to the original starting grid.
So all the cars were sat in the pit lane and they just had to move the cars around in the pit lane.
And I thought that site was really funny.
But then they had a rolling restart, and like I said, it was the original grid order because they didn't even make it past turn one.
In terms of the actual racing, after the red flag ended and they actually started the race,
there was a fight between Icosi, Powell, and Alassari.
And it was genuinely the scariest thing I've had to witness.
Because I know Icosi is a clean driver, and obviously I know that Powell is a clean driver.
But it was still scary.
They were just constantly fighting each other.
And I was scared.
I was scared that he was going to get crashed out.
But he did not.
Well, kind of.
Alassari went off the track, rejoined the track, pushed Powell off.
Powell rejoined behind Alassari.
And luckily there was a little bit of gap between the fight that was going on and the guys behind them.
But Alassari ended up DNFing anyways.
But I'm still mad that he didn't get a grid penalty for the next race for an unsafe rejoin that could have very easily taken Powell out of the race.
But yeah, so this DNF plus the DNF in the previous race, like we said earlier,
had some big championship implications for Alassari.
There were, there was like no green laps during that sprint race.
Like I don't remember if we had a single full green lap at all.
But I guess that kind of helped Toisenroder, and in the end he ended up winning the race.
Um, I think this is the first win for Campos, like during the main season.
And obviously there was the race win for Powell in Harama that got taken away.
But in the main YR3 season, this is Campos' first win, and it's a reverse grid win, which is so embarrassing.
Um, there were a bunch of penalties again.
Um, Ferrari, Steven Hayden's and Kota all got 10 seconds for using push to pass after the safety car ended, but before crossing the start-finish line.
Again, Steven Hayden's got a reprimand for starting the engine, starting his engine before the one minute board,
which is actually a bit interesting to me because we've discussed this during F4,
and the F4 drivers get a penalty for doing this.
But it seems it's just a reprimand for Eurocup 3.
So I'm not sure why there's a difference in that.
But yeah.
Um, Dallagnol got a three-place grid drop for colliding with Perard.
Some teammate-on-teammate crime going on during that race.
And Steven Hayden's gets another penalty for 10 seconds for causing a collision with Barboy.
We've had a lot of penalties those first two races.
Why is everyone getting penalties?
Who's not gotten penalized at this point?
I feel like everyone is getting a penalty.
Powell.
Powell didn't get penalized.
The colour wheel.
Exactly.
However, there were no penalties after race two.
Race two was really clean, surprisingly.
Igosi won the race, obviously.
We're back to Igosi dominance.
He won the race by like five seconds ahead of Perard.
Perard was under investigation for a jump start, but he just didn't get a penalty,
which is weird because I thought that if you get noted for a jump start,
it's like 99% of the time you will get the penalty for it.
But he didn't get a penalty for it.
I don't know what was up with that.
Shtuka got his first podium of the season.
He seems to really enjoy Imola, apparently.
There was only one safety car the entire race,
which is surprising considering the sprint race was basically all safety car.
The commentators joked that maybe the drivers just weren't awake enough,
so they were just driving carefully.
But the safety car happened.
There was a little bit of fighting for position lower down in the field,
and Kampos, the driver, not the team,
ended up with a broken suspension and parked it on the grass.
That's where the only safety car the race came from.
No post-race penalties.
Not even a single driver investigated after the race.
For once, we have a clean Eurocup 3 race.
Wow.
There was a big fight in the points between Lammers, Strava, Pradell, Ferrari, and Thunion.
They were all just a bunch of fighting for position again.
At one point, I think Pradell was telling Ferrari to not fight him,
or that he wasn't going to fight him so that they could catch up to the guys ahead,
which the commentators mentioned that that's usually a karting thing,
and that it doesn't happen a lot in car racing,
but I thought that was interesting.
By the end of the race, Thunion got a puncture,
and we didn't get a replay of what happened to him,
but he just stopped on the side,
and because it was the last lap of the race,
they just yellow flagged it and there was no safety car.
There were a couple drivers that didn't start the race after the big crash in the sprint,
including Tarn Vinicickel.
I don't remember who else didn't start the race,
but Powell started two positions higher than he should have because of it.
So he started P14 instead of P16.
He ended the race in P11,
which I'm a little bit sad about because he was so close to points.
But overall, the campus drivers were kind of struggling with pace a bit throughout the
entire race.
Well, not the entire race.
About halfway through the race,
all three of them just suddenly lost any sense of being able to overtake or defend position.
Heusenroeder lost a couple places,
Powell just dropped off of the back of that big fight for the points,
and Straubin was kind of struggling to defend against the guys behind him.
He did successfully manage to defend against them,
but you could tell he was struggling.
Um, Powell was like two seconds behind that huge fight,
and by the end of the race, he was like eight tenths behind them.
So he did manage to make up a bit of time,
but like not enough to actually get into the fight, unfortunately.
Um, but yeah, like I said, no penalties, no post-race investigations, no nothing.
So the results of the race were final, like as soon as the race ended.
Um, in terms of the championship, obviously, Igosi leads, um, on 142 points.
Behind him is not Al-Azharie, but it is Ian Eichmanns on 86 points.
That is a very big gap.
He batted 56 points, I think, and to think without a DNF in race one,
that would have been 25 points.
It would have been like 80 points or something, which is insane.
Um, Al-Azharie is in P3 now on 74 points.
Delaniel is P4 on 68, Lammer is P5 on 56, and Powell is in P6 on 49.
Powell has managed to close down the gap to the guys ahead of him a little bit,
because after that double DNF in Portimao, he was like quite a bit far, like quite a bit far back.
Um, and not mentioned in the doc, but one thing that I do remember is that
Kasper Stuka is on 47 points.
So he is like right on the back of Powell as well.
Um, in terms of the team's championship, are we surprised that Pillow is leading?
Nope, we're never surprised when the name Pillow is leading.
As I said, he's a witch.
Um, MP Motorsport is second on, uh, wait, Pillow is first obviously on 216 points,
MP behind them on 160.
Um, Campos is in P3 on 108, Hi-Tech P4 on 100, and Technicar is on 47.
Um, which I just realized, Stuka was literally, um, on 47 points.
So Stuka drives for Technicar, right?
Yes, he does.
Yeah, so he's scored every single one of Technicar's points.
I love how we predicted a Campos-Hi-Tech title fight, and they're fighting for third.
Campos-MP, not Campos-Hi-Tech.
Oh yeah.
But you know, I don't think anyone expected this Pillow-Mursport domination.
Yeah, no, I don't think so.
Yeah, that's it for Eurocup 3.
And to continue on our bad predictions, E4.
E4, enough to trust our race and just go with us racing with.
They suddenly continued their strength.
I don't like it.
Um, anyways, I don't think E4 even started out normal from its first quality,
considering that we had Kamiyab on pole.
And our race qualified P2 for one of the races, I mean.
Um, I remember for quality, that was like, I remember getting my hopes up,
seeing like Salma Lista.
I forgot why he qualified, but he was so low on the list.
I was like, oh my gosh, maybe the curse is over.
I thought I was free.
A Prema was on pole.
We were free for like five minutes.
Oh my god.
Race one, um.
I mean, the Machinani, Kamiyab, I mean, first Salma Lista was on pole for the third race.
But the first two poles were by Prema.
Ms. Goodbro, calm.
But only in E4.
I mean, yeah, and then race one.
Oh my god, what a snoozer this was.
Really did not expect F4 to be this boring.
Like, a couple other races this weekend were like quite boring,
but like, you'd think that F4 would be a bit more interesting.
The main thing I remember from this race was Kamiyab just falling back in at pole start.
He was starting P2, then he kind of fell backward,
but that's literally all that happened.
Oh, I think even the drivers were bored,
because none of them decided to slow under yellow flags.
Oh yes, of course.
Um, that was all funny.
Post race, like, way after the race,
we get a document that says every single driver in the field got 35 seconds.
For not slowing under yellow flags.
Every single one of them.
Imagine if, like, one back marker decided to actually respect the yellow flags,
and he would have won, despite being like P28 on the road.
That would have been even, that's all we needed to make the situation even funnier.
Like, someone did the math of how much each driver slowed down,
because you're supposed to slow down about 15%
compared to your sector in your previous lap.
I think the most a driver slowed down was, like, 7%.
And some of them sped up, some of them were faster than their previous laps.
But yeah, in terms of the RS drivers,
because obviously that's what I care about,
the Kairos brothers had a great introduction to the series.
One of them got murdered by Kuklani.
I don't know, this guy seems to hate the RS drivers,
because remember that one time he was involved in an incident with Emily?
And the other Kairos brother ended up in an incident with Thomas Behrman,
and it was deemed to be the Kairos brother's fault.
I don't know which one's which.
I can't tell.
I mean, I think it's just the RS experience,
either getting crashed into, or crashing into someone.
Exactly.
And look, even race 2 was quite boring.
Except for when Andi Gonsani decided it was a good idea to just
ram into the back of Noah Killian.
Maybe it was revenge for when Killian took his P2.
They simply hate us racing like we do.
That's what it is.
He is anti-us racing.
But yeah, I feel like this entire season I've been complaining about Andi's luck,
but at this point it isn't just his luck,
it's that he's not that clean of a driver, unfortunately.
And obviously some things have been that he has just had horrific luck,
but at the same time there are things that you can blame him for, like this incident.
He did get 6 places for the next race,
which he was already starting P13, so he ended up starting the race in P19.
But I mean, who won?
Kenzo.
This is the first win of the Italian season.
I got really emotional during the race,
because Salvestrin mentioned that our race's last win in Italian F4, like Euro 4,
was Alex's win in Mugello.
Mugello Martin.
Yeah, so very happy with the Kenzo win.
I wish Andi locked in a little bit,
because he was fighting for, I think, where was he, like P7 or something at the time?
Yeah, because we were joking.
We were joking about Bondarev and Kansani fighting for P7 again.
Yeah, guys, UAE 4 champion and runner-up fighting for P7 in Europe, that's so sad.
Meanwhile, you have women coming up in the podium petitions.
I'm so surprised considering he's so new to car racing.
But he did really well at IF4 Vallelunga, so I was like, okay, I guess, fair.
Yeah, I was surprised.
Good for him, and hopefully he can maybe keep this up.
It's been a bit of a messy weekend, but I think all the other guys, a lot of them have done,
they did UAE 4, they've done the whole, he came halfway.
He came in the second weekend or something of Italian, I think.
But yeah, this race kind of shows the duality of RSGP, either you're winning or you're nowhere.
Oh my god, Race 3.
Race 3 clashed with F1, and I couldn't tell what was going on in either race.
It didn't help that there was no commentary.
Yeah, there was no commentary for the first almost half the race, and then we got to the first
safety car, and then suddenly we could hear Salveston.
But the thing is that there was audio, you could hear something from the commentary booth,
because there were multiple times during the race where I would be listening to E4,
and there would just be Italians speaking, but it sounded like someone on the phone just got
really close to the mic, and then they would walk away, and I was just like, wait a minute,
and so I couldn't keep track of everything.
It was so weird, because I was trying, usually when stuff clashes with F1, I prioritize the
feeder series over F1 in terms of commentary, because I cannot listen to more than one commentary
at once, but we had no commentary.
Yeah, and oh, before anything, something really weird happened for E4, Race 3, where
Mackignani just did not start, which was weird, because he just didn't start Race 3, and I think
they might have probably was trying to tell us what happened, probably in the commentary before
the race started, but seeing as we didn't have any race commentary coming through the stream,
we just don't know.
I initially thought he was involved in an incident in Race 2 or something, and they couldn't fix the
car in time, but he wasn't.
He just did not start for God knows why.
George Froudford Nolder was having a pretty decent weekend up until Race 3, where he just
crashed into Bernaldi and had them both DNF, which gave him a 6th place grid drop for the next race,
which would obviously be next weekend, like next race weekend, I mean.
At one point, something happened to Tamar Skander.
I don't know what happened to him, but they killed him.
I couldn't tell what was happening again.
Yeah, I think this was when Chartier crashed into him, I think, but that was like,
it was like earlier on in the race when we still didn't have commentary, so
you could only really just see him fall down the order, and that's all we got.
But Chartier got a 6th position drop for the next race.
And we know our opinions on TV Direction.
There was a bit more contact between a bunch of other drivers.
Orsini and Rodriguez ended up in a collision, and Kerling took root out, us racing downfall anyone?
Please?
And the race ended under safety car.
So can we just make us racing on the guest anymore?
Did we talk about us racing shenanigans or no?
We should mention the penalties first.
So like we mentioned a couple of them already,
Chartier got 6 places and then also got 8 places on top of that.
For, he killed two of the R races.
Rodriguez got 6 places, Kerling got 6 places,
Bradford Noldor got 6 places, and Kamiab got 10 seconds.
What did he get 10 seconds for?
Yeah, that's the thing.
Oh no, it was the very last bit where, oh yeah, nevermind, I do remember now.
At the penultimate lap or so, or a little bit later,
he made contact with Kerling, like basically last lap move, and I think that might have been it.
At one point, Killian got a fine, or like us racing got a fine
for sending Killian out in like an unsafe release into the pit lane.
And us racing were trying to appeal that penalty.
However, during like when they were summoned for the penalty originally,
the team manager of us racing got really aggressive with both the officials and
the team manager of the PHM team, including some sort of verbal abuse.
And like the reasoning that they were using to try and appeal the fine was that,
oh like another driver or like another team broke the rules first, so that means we shouldn't get
punished for breaking the rules ourselves, because I think it was that someone was already in the
fast lane of the pit lane. Yeah, Oscar Rapetto from PHM, which is why the PHM team manager was there.
Yeah, so Rapetto was already in the pit lane, in the fast lane, when he wasn't supposed to be.
And so us racing had released Noah Killian into his path or something like that,
something about an unsafe release. So us racing were trying to argue that there was a driver in
the fast lane when there shouldn't have been, so therefore we did not break the rules.
And the stewards said that, you know, if you had seen an incident, you should have reported it to us.
And then us racing were trying to argue that like it's not our responsibility to report incidents.
And then there was another document that came out about the verbal abuse that the us racing manager
was doing. And apparently both the PREMA and the AKM team managers were outside the stewards' room,
and they overheard what was happening. So the fact that the us racing team manager was loud enough
that people outside the room could hear him, that's insane. And it's worrying. How is a person like
that allowed to run a team of children? This is an F4 team.
It makes you almost wonder how they treat their staff and how they treat their drivers behind
closed doors. It's quite worrying that they even act like this in front of officials and stewards.
So weird. But yeah, so all this over, what was it, 2,000 euros, which obviously is a lot to us,
but to a successful team, I don't think that's that much. But yeah, I don't know. I think they
did try to appeal, and I don't think anything's come out of that yet. But I guess we'll see.
I just thought that was really concerning. Anyways, in terms of the championships,
oh my god. Samalisto obviously leads on 86 points. However,
Kinzo Kregi is the second, which makes me very happy. He's 30 points behind Samalisto on 56
points. Bondarev is right behind him as well on 52. Samankov is P4 on 42, and Azoi is also
on 42, but is in P5. And in terms of the team's championship, Us Racing is on 150 points,
but they're not that far ahead of Prema, actually. Prema's on 130.
R-Race is in P3 on 70 points, and then VAR is in fourth on 14, and then Trident is P5 on 8 points.
I think you can kind of tell the fact that Prema has 7 cars, Us Racing has 7 cars,
and R-Race has 5, so they're basically taking up all of the points positions.
No one else can get points anyways. Yeah, there were multiple points during
the races where I was like, let's look at who's occupying the positions, and literally the entire
time it was like, top 14 is Prema, Us, and R-Race, and then P15 would be like a VAR,
and it's like Thomas Behrmann, and I'm like, okay, fair.
I feel bad for the smaller teams that can't score any points because
R-Race, Us Racing, and Prema are all just hogging the points. It was worse last year
when the points were top 10, at least this year it's top 15.
But yeah, that's it. The championships are kind of funny-looking, but that's it for our E4.
And like we said, E4 is basically IF4 2.0, so it's not surprising that the standings look
practically the same. But yeah, that's it.
So moving on to F1 Academy. Okay, I think we should all be aware that
I'm a huge fan of F1 Academy, and this weekend I think saw one of the most interesting things
happen in recent history of F1 Academy, which is not long anyway.
We had a white card with Tiaga Besik, which is important to me that we all pronounce the,
I don't know how to say it in English, but little dots above the A, it's important.
And she is by far the most accomplished wild card I've seen so far in the edition of Wild
Cards in the 2024 season. I was honestly, or I'll go through the weakness first. So training she
was by far the quickest, and really impressive because a lot of people and I said before,
she's in a high tech. The Wild Card Driver this year is in a high tech, and if you watch
F1 Academy, you should be aware that I kind of considered one of the worst cards because
it's unclear if the problem is that they have the least experienced drivers with the least
backing of F1 teams, or if the performance is just that between itself is good.
But this weekend we saw also the other two high tech drivers,
Ava Dobson and Rachel Robertson, and I was wondering how far both for high tech and the drivers
that could be based on the fact that both the team and the drivers are based pretty much in,
I wouldn't say that they're not necessarily based, they all race a lot.
I expect them to know this track from place are the best, and in qualifying it went on
pretty much the same with Chiara leading pretty dominantly, in front of Alicia Homovsky, who
I don't know is kind of the favorite already, and we all saw that she was very far ahead of other
drivers so far. But, and here is the track where I think it becomes really interesting. We saw
Lisa Villard in P3, which is already a really good thing for her because I think we all expect
that, maybe not more from, but the fact that she is sponsored by Gatorade and not by NA4T
has already been pleasing to some people, and the fact that she's with ART, who are another
considerably weak team, has also made some people raise their eyebrows, me included,
but she had her best qualifying, that's really good I think. But also I think it's important to
point out other good performances by Dobson and Robertson, as I mentioned, you know, a high-tech
whole thing. If no one wants to throw anything in, I'm open, I'm just rattling down on my thoughts.
So either they aren't interested or I'm unfathomable either ways. For not so good
performances, we saw ART once again three spots down, and I think that it's, I don't think it's
her problem, but as far as I saw, she was again her problem. Very similar to Eloic,
it's also been experienced with Trump at the start. So for the reverse race,
I saw a lot of people saying it was wrong, or please please edit the icons if I just don't
wrap it up. But we saw a little bit less from Bertha Gryffoel, which is, on one hand that's
a good thing for her to take points, she's second in standing, she wants to take any points she can
get to oppose Alicia, but on the other hand, it's just P8 and Bertha Gryffoel. And the planet
podium was made up of her, Dina Gaideman and Eloid, who did a pretty solid race, but overall
we all pretty much saw the fact that these cars just did not really work at first. I felt like
there's no, it was kind of too big from my view, because the cars are barely comparable
low, and they don't have any gimmick, any other suits, they don't have DRX, they don't have
push-to-pads and nothing, so it's kind of difficult to overtake around here.
And we saw it, because, especially in the front, very little happened. The point is,
Alicia did a few overtakes, Chiara got up the line fairly slow and got overtaken, and the final
fight, or the only real overtaking on the race, was between Megan Bruce, Ava Thompson and Chiara
Batik, where Chiara Batik came out on top in P8 again, where she started, which was kind of,
I mean, she held herself pretty well, she didn't crash, I think, but her start was not,
you know, the best, but it's always something to work on, and other than that, nothing happened.
Race two was much the same, there was not much things happening, except for Eloid, but I think
it was five, which was really good, it was really good performance by her to overtake so much,
other than that, Unsha, once again, won the race, did Chiara at not the best start, and
I think it's kind of round about it. I think the most important part is really,
people were really impressed by Chiara leading both practice and the qualifying, even if she
didn't end up winning, she's the first wildcard driver to take a podium, which is already, I think,
quite a performance that, you know, I kind of expected it in 2024 from Ellie Charles, when
she would have started P4, but the race cancelled. It was Chiara, I think, but anyways,
I think performance, a lot of us are expecting to see her do so well, and I think it's round about
it, because no one knows of anything that you say, and please don't let me give you the outro,
because the only thing that I know is that I will be at British F4 next week, and if everything
goes right, I can tell some funny stories from that, what I saw, like. So that should be all for
this week's episode. Next week, there's really not that much going on, but we should be covering
British F4, and that's about it. So yeah, thank you.